♪ Tea with GaryVee. ♪
♪ Just text your questions
and no stressing ♪
♪ 'Cause you're sipping tea ♪
♪ Tea with GaryVee. ♪
- Hello world. Good morning.
Good afternoon if you're in Europe,
good evening if you're in Asia.
April 7th, Tuesday morning,
I got my big fucking mug.
It is tea with Gary Vee
and I'm super thrilled
that you're here with me.
Thank you so much.
Before we get into it,
grab out your phones immediately.
Do one of two things.
Take a screenshot of this
right now and share it.
I just tweeted.
If you're part of the tea
with GaryVee community
and you're not on Twitter interacting
with me at Gary V-E-E
you're making a huge mistake
following, re-tweeting, engaging,
and building a real community.
I just tweeted the URL to
YouTube where this is live
and please retweet that
and add your two cents.
Get everybody on here before
we get into the calls.
Big shout outs to all
the comments right now.
Let's take a look.
Farnaz what's good?
Karim what's good on Facebook?
Deep Fact on YouTube.
What is up Tyler Rachleff
real, real good morning to you.
I like what you're doing Dustin.
Get these comments up hardcore
right off the back sore.
What's up?
Barry Izembam.
Really nice to have you here.
Thank you so much, Jonathan Jonson.
What's good chef?
What's good, Tony?
What is up?
I'm really excited to have everybody here.
Our Hunter.
What's good, Chris Quinn?
It's a lot of fun.
Also big, big opportunity today.
If you drink Rose, Rose,
put it up right here.
One of the best California
Rose's dismantles
whispering angel.
If you are not on WineText,
you're making a huge mistake.
Yesterday was crazy.
20 minutes we sold out of that cab
that I was telling you about.
Today's offer Brane and
I worked on for months,
one of the best Rose's, a $30 Rose,
at a ridiculous price.
I'm really excited
about it should sell out
within 20 minutes as well.
So if you drink Rose,
if you need some more Rose
during this quarantine,
I highly recommend you
get on WineText right now.
Get that off.
Let's get to the first call.
This is T with Gary
Vee rock dance theater.
What's good?
Morning.
- Hey Gary.
Good morning.
- Good morning.
What's your name? Where you from?
- Hey, I'm Ditto.
I'm in LA and I don't have any tea,
but I'm trying to wake up.
I'm trying to--
- I get it , it's early.
I appreciate the hustle
6:00a.m., I appreciate it.
- Yeah, yeah.
Thank you so much for having me.
I have a question for you.
So on my social platforms for a while,
I've been making great videos
and I've been building
such a cool community,
but anytime I switch something up
they sort of like throw a fit.
I get a lot of,
"I missed the old her" comments
and I wanted to know is there something
I'm doing wrong?
Is there something I'm not doing
that could make us kind
of grow together better?
I don't wanna leave them hanging.
- What were the videos you were making
and what are some of the
stuff you're mixing in?
- Yes, so I primarily make dance videos
and I do a lot of robotics
and a lot of tutting and things like that.
And let's say I didn't
tut a lot in a video,
or I dance to a different kind of music,
they're freaking out.
They're like, "I just
missed the old Ditto."
- I get it.
Ditto went through this hard, hard in 2009
so I did three years every day,
five days a week on early
YouTube of Wine Videos.
I was one of the first YouTubers
especially doing long
form and it was all wine.
And then I was like,"Yo,
"I wanna talk about business,"
'cause that's really what I am.
And I started making business
videos and people fucking lost
their mind out of anger,
just didn't like it.
Any time that I've taken a
step in my business career,
got a TV appearance or had a viral,
a micro viral video or popped off
or hang out with somebody,
immediately people are like,
"You're different, you
changed, we miss this,
"we miss that."
The reality is you can't get caught up
in the comments or the likes or views.
You just can't, you have to evolve,
and they have to follow you
and you have that conviction.
I've watched so many people not change
their shit up even though they want to
because they don't like the fact
that they get more negative comments
and they get less engagement.
It's a huge mistake.
You've got to stay the course
you're going through your life.
You can't be the same girl
you were three years ago
- Yeah, I cannot, oh my gosh, I cannot.
- And your self esteem and
your self worth can't be
how many followers or how
much engagement you get
on Instagram, it just can't.
- Yeah,
- And right now we're in a generation
where people are starting
to think that way.
- Right, Yeah.
It's a scary thing.
I mean, when we're living
off these brand deals
and that's how we pay our rent
and it's really easy for me
to get paranoid about it.
I'm at a point now where I'm comfortable
and I'm ready to say,
I'll let my engagement go down.
I'll do this, I just
wanna like my own content
- 100% and I promise you, when
you like your own content,
that shit comes back so often,
especially if you have talent.
- Wow, thank you.
- Listen, and another thing,
I'd rather you live in a
little less fancy apartment,
I'd rather you buy one less nice thing,
go on one less trip
than fucking be unhappy.
We have to make happiness
the fucking Northstar,
not fucking money or clout.
We have to
and you have responsibility
You have a huge fan base.
And so you have to show and lead the way
and then make a video
about it and be like,
"Yo, I love you fuckers,
but I am changing too."
- All right, yeah.
I want them to feel like
they're growing with me.
- Speak to them, speak
to them, do your shit,
and then the sixth video
will be like, I love you.
I'm so grateful for you, but I'm evolving
and so are you
and I appreciate and,
by the way.
I'll fucking pop and lock for you
once in a blue moon for old time's sake,
but I gotta do me.
- I swear, yeah, that's what I tell them.
I'm like, "Hey, you miss
the old me, the videos?
"They're still up."
- Exactly.
And you can bring it out of
the back once in a blue moon,
you know.
- Right.
- Good luck.
Thank you for getting up so early.
- Thank you.
- Talk to you soon.
All right, let's keep this going
Tea with Gary Vee please share it.
Screenshoot it let's get people in here.
I know there's some
Facebook groups watching.
Big shout out to everybody.
Reddit, big shout out to you LinkedIn.
I know you're in the building.
Big shout out to all of you guys as well.
Samuel on Facebook.
What's good?
Hi.
- Hi, hi, how are you?
Good morning.
- Good morning.
- Hi, I'm Brooklyn, a queen from Detroit.
I'm 14 I'm a artist and influencer.
So my question for you
is what would you tell--
What advice would you
give your 14 year old self
based on everything that you know now?
- So my advice might be a
little bit tricky for you,
but I'll give it to you and then
if I can give you a followup,
I'll let you know.
For me it would have been like, look,
14 was a real big year for me
'cause it's when my baseball card business
started to really pop
and my dad dragged me
into the liquor store and
I was working every weekend
and every summer vacation.
So I was in a real
transition where I was like,
"Okay, now I'm grown
and I'm doing business,
"fuck school."
So really the advice I
would've given that kid is,
this is gonna be such an
enjoyable part of your life.
You're about to learn
so many of the skills
that you're gonna use
the rest of your life.
So enjoy that.
I probably would have told him
not to go 100 into business and save
and really push back
against his dad and himself,
and have a little bit of summer vacation,
maybe two weeks to hang out with friends.
But, honestly that was a
big transition year for me,
and, was really the year
that my career started
in a lot of ways.
- Right.
- What about for you?
Instead of that question,
what about for you, what is
the most challenging part
of being this young and
having this much attention
on you?
- The most challenging part--
- Are you happy, happy, happy?
- Yes.
This is my dream.
This is definitely gonna be the thing
that I do for the rest of my life.
- So can I tell you something?
I'll give you something that
I think could really help.
Don't get too high on
the positive feedback.
When you read the comments
and people are like,
"You're amazing, you're pretty,
"you're smart, you're amazing,
"you're so talented."
Don't get too high on that
because what that's gonna do
is let you deal when people
say you're shit, you fell off,
you're not good.
When you start getting quiet
and it's about you for you,
not the audience's feedback,
I think it will put you in
a much more stable place
to go and do your thing.
- Right.
When people come on my page with
the negative things.
I'm just the type of person that...
'Cause being a public figure,
you're gonna get bullied
every day on social media,
like on your lives, on
your posts, on everything.
So I'm just the type of person that
I wouldn't say don't care,
but I just don't feed
into the negative energy.
- I love that.
And as a matter of fact,
if you can start this at 14,
it'll put you in such a great spot.
If you could flip it
from not caring to
actually having compassion
to that person.
- Right.
- For somebody to go on your page
and try to drag you down,
they're fucking hurting inside.
- Yeah.
- You understand?
- And I'll sometimes even
someone could comment something like,
you're disgusting or you're ugly.
And then I go to their page
and I like a picture
and then they're like,
"Oh my gosh, thank you so much."
So they'd like turn into a supporter
- Listen, one of the biggest
things that helped me
was my ability to be the bigger man.
When people came at me
with heat and negativity,
I always did stuff like that.
I was like, look, I'm sorry,
that you feel that way, but I
wish you happiness and health.
I'd go give them love like that.
I used to go on their page.
I love that about you.
If you've got that now you're on your way.
Just try not to get too high.
Trying to get too low and
always, always create.
Never hold back, like
don't ever, ever, ever not
put out your voice and your thoughts.
Keep sharing, 'cause you
never know when a thought
in your head that you didn't put out
was actually the thought
that would change the world.
So the last piece before we bounce here is
make sure you put out the content.
Don't overthink the music.
Don't overthink the videos.
Put what's in your fucking
heart and your head.
- Yes.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
Thanks for watching.
- Thank you for toning me in.
- Yep.
Talk to you soon.
That girl's mind is right
at 14, she's gonna win.
That girl is gonna win.
That's a lock.
I'm excited for her.
Danny Waters, what's good,
Maryanne Senebrino
What's good TJ Thomas, love you back.
Metcalf's meet the Metcalf's.
What's up Ginger Beloved.
So good to see you.
Big shout out.
Let's see what's going on on Twitter.
Nope.
Hello.
- Hello.
- Good morning.
- How are you?
- Good, how you doing today?
- I'm really well.
- Good morning.
- Wonderful, my name is Tara Mathy.
I'll give you a little bit of back story
to frame my question, 'cause
I have a question for you.
I have two bestselling books.
I have an organic beauty company.
I am an influencer.
I sing, I speak, which is all wonderful,
but I had to pivot a lot
of that business model
this year because I can't
sing live, I can't speak live,
retail is kinda out right now.
So I'm focused 100% on
my eCommerce business.
So we're focused right now on education,
the education around the product since
it's organic beauty products,
the education around staying safe
and reduce anxiety and what's
going on in the world today,
and we're starting up
a very large ambassador program
we're sending out emails
two or three times a week,
we're updating our Instagram
two or three times a day.
I wanna know if you
have any specific advice
for at this point in time,
building a recession smart
'cause I don't know if there's
any such thing as a recession proof,
but a recession smart business,
in this time of such uncertainty
about what the world's gonna look like
in the next few months,
in the next year, et cetera.
- So first of all, it's
really running a business
that has a real good grasp of its overhead
and its profit margins, right?
So really looking at your
expenses, first of all,
because a lot of good
entrepreneurs and good influencers
are very good at focusing on the offense,
but they're not as strong at
looking at the bottom line.
So, A, definitely, definitely
looking at your economics,
how profitable are the
products you're selling
on the eCommerce site and then
who's surrounding you, right?
In the world of influencers,
the things that nature,
too many people have too many assistants,
too many content creators,
too many glam squad.
So being very thoughtful
about that, right?
And then really it's about
building top of the funnel,
brand awareness during this time.
I actually think that the
economy is gonna be...
I don't know what kind of recession
we're really looking at.
I think the biggest
variable that nobody knows
is what happens with the pandemic,
the disease during the fall and winter.
How much or how little
does it come back, right?
To me that's the biggest thing
that's on my mind.
But I think you should definitely assume
to bunker down for a year, right?
A hardcore year,
and I think in that year,
tightening up the expenses
and then also really focusing
on expansion.
So where are you at
with Tik Tok?
- I just hopped down there
probably like a month ago.
- And what are you doing?
Zero a day?
One a day, one every four days?
- Pretty much zero a day at this point.
I'm mostly learning
what other people are doing
and where I can best create content
that actually serves people
and isn't just me
learning some viral dance,
which does nothing for anybody.
- Right.
I've got 3.3 million followers
and a huge audience there and I--
- And you talk about Tik
Tok forever by the way.
You have been OG Tik Tok for like probably
since the day it came out.
You have been telling people about Tik Tok
on every platform.
So I appreciate that
- And I can't dance for shit
- You don't need to
- And I think you don't need to either.
You have to immediately listen to me.
- When did you get on Instagram
and what happened?
- I probably got Instagram in 2014,
my first book came out in 2016
but I got my book deal in
2014 my publishing company
reached out they found my blog.
So at 2016 I got great
PR for my first book,
becoming a number one bestseller
and that attracted a
large Instagram audience
and then it really built from there.
But I've found that
engagement is going down,
numbers are coming down.
- It happens on every platform.
- Yeah.
- It's already happened
on Tik Tok to the people
I got on Tik Tok 15 months ago.
- Is it really?
- Yes.
You have to listen to me.
You, you, you have to post two,
three times a day on Tik Tok
- Okay, okay.
- You have like today.
- Okay.
- It's so important and let me
tell you why it's important.
There's still land grab,
it's not as crazy as
it was, 15 months ago.
Like anybody could've post
something and it went viral,
but it's time to post,
and more importantly the
things you're gonna learn
in posting the next platform...
YouTube is working on
the Tik Tok competitor
right now and YouTube's a
wildly important platform,
whether that pops or not,
everything evolves off
of everything.
So Socialcam led to Vine
and Vine led to Snapchat
and Snapchat to Instagram Stories
and Instagram stories...
You can't skip over being
a creative for Tik Tok
because being a creator
and putting out content
is gonna be forever.
- Yeah, I don't wanna sleep on it.
I really don't wanna sleep on it.
It's just about finding my niche of
what it means and learning.
Make, make what you make on Instagram
and fucking write over, just fucking make.
You didn't know what to do
on fucking Instagram either,
just make
- It's true.
It's so true.
- One of the things that catches people
is when they're successful
for the first time
on another platform, they struggle
with the perception of not being big
on the current platform
and I wanna get you out of that.
That's why celebrities got fucked.
They all didn't go on Instagram
in 2013, '14, '15, '16, '17
because they were real celebrities
and then all of a sudden
Instagram celebrities
became real celebrities and got caught,
- Right yeah.
And now they're all in Tik Tok.
All the celebrities are on Tik Tok.
- You have to do it, Tara,
you have to do it.
- Thank you, Gary.
I really appreciate that.
Thank you so, so much.
- Economics and costs on your retail.
- Yep.
- And really go ham on Tik Tok.
I'm telling you it'll work.
- Awesome.
Thank you brother.
I appreciate you.
- All right, let's keep this going Dustin.
Are we getting dudes today?
Four ladies in a row,
this is amazing.
It's ladies morning.
I love this.
Jackie, what's good?
- Hey, how are you?
- I'm really well.
I come to you from Wichita Falls, Texas.
Thank you.
It's so great.
I drive into the city to
run my advertising agency,
but I live on a farm with cows,
so I'm a dairy farmer's daughter
and a dairy farmers wife.
It's so good to just drive
in and see the sunrise,
but I can't thank you enough for spending
just a few minutes with me this morning.
My question today is,
our agency, is very
heartfelt and aggressive
and what I love most about
you is you're an open book
to every agency across the United States.
You teach us your craft and
we dive in and we learn it
and we absorb it.
We are two weeks into a shelter city
and all of our local
clients are getting antsy
and their anxiety has
gone up a level Gary,
and they're nervous.
So now they're thinking,
"Jackie, I know you're telling us
"to double down on social media
"and tell our story--"
- Jackie, I--
- There, did I lose you?
- You're back, you're back.
- Can you hear me?
- Double down, tell your
story, I'm listening, go ahead
- Okay, sorry about that.
So what I need is Gary,
how do I tell these local
clients don't give up.
Now's not the time to give up.
You gotta stay the course.
Keep telling your story.
Does that make sense?
- It does.
I want some clarification.
Are we talking about organic creative
or are you asking them to
run media amplification?
- I can't hear.
- You can't hear me?
We're gonna get you on
Jackie, you can't hear?
Turn it off, we'll get you back on.
- Let's wait.
I can hear both of you.
- Oh, you can?
- Yeah.
- Jackie, Jackie, can you hear me?
- Okay, you can hear me?
Can you hear me or no?
She can hear you Dustin.
Tell her to turn it off and
then to come right back on.
- I'm here Dustin.
I can't hear him but I
think he can hear me.
- Just try reloading the
page and then come back
and then we'll be here.
- Okay, I'll come right back
'cause I really want the
answer to that great question.
- You will get it Jackie.
- All right.
I'm gonna give some shout outs
while Jackie's trying to get back out.
Big shout out to L. Emily,
Nate Dizzy on Facebook.
Never give up hitting record
numbers in sales right now.
Good job.
I appreciate that.
Let's take a little break right now
and everybody take a screenshot
and share this, let's get that going.
I am feeling on fire Vince
Lester, big shout out to you.
Part of the YouTube community.
I appreciate that.
Let's see what else is going on here.
Caleb Dustin is putting in work.
I agree.
Carl Daniel Davidson.
What's good?
Eric Toronto, Tyler Ratliff.
She is awesome Jeremy.
I'm excited to get her right back.
Junior Softy I love that jersey short.
Let's go.
- Hey, thank you Gary,
for letting me come back.
- You're welcome.
Can you hear me?
- Yes, I can.
That was my dad calling in by the way.
- I love it.
Big shout out to dad.
So the question that I have is,
are you telling them to
double down on organic content
or are you asking them to
double down on media spend
on their social or other channels?
- Yeah, I think organic
is so important today,
but with a little bit of spend,
but your message,
I tell them that their message changes.
You have to be more
authentic today than ever
and speak from the heart,
and they're just nervous,
every time they think,
are we in this for 30 days, 60 days.
Now they're saying August,
we have to save every penny we've got.
And I go, "I get it, I get it, but--"
- So, is this a
conversation of them wanting
to potentially stop the scope
with you for a time being?
- Yes.
- Look, I think you have to
be very balanced here.
Oh, Jack, hold on, hold on.
Get your cup up?
We got the big cup mugs.
I like that.
Listen, you're gonna have to
eat your own dog food here.
You also are gonna have to be courageous.
I've had a ton of conversations
with clients that are
teetering and the reality
is when you're talking to small businesses
and obviously we have The Sasha Group
and things of that nature,
you have to be empathetic.
You yourself are a small business
and first and foremost you have to worry
about your business, your employees.
However, when you're giving advice,
you actually have to give advice.
So what I would do if I were you
is double click into the convo.
If you figured out that Sarah with her,
flower shop does have the savings
and the financial
wherewithal to get through,
two years, well then Sarah's opportunity
to go crazy right now.
If Rick in the thrift
store is in a little bit
more of a financial pickle,
the advice might be to
say to Rick, "Listen,
"why don't you pay me half,
"for the next three months,"
You have to be empathetic
and you have to tighten up yourself.
Your advice during this time
to the people that pay you
is something that will be your reputation
and your financial impact
for the next three decades.
- Yeah, I get it
- Because you know how it is.
If they're paying you
and they're on the phone
and they're feeling like the only reason
you're giving me the advice
is so that you're still paying,
that's gonna change the dynamic.
So you have to dig a little bit deeper.
I spent 45 minutes with every
client to really understand
and some of them I said, "Look,
"it is a good time for you to pause.
"I don't like what I'm hearing."
That was at my detriment short term.
Sure I may have to have a layoff,
I may have to cut expenses,
but it's the right advice
and for the reputation
and the legacy and most of all for me,
putting my fucking head on my pillow,
it was the right advice.
- Yeah,
- And you have to be specific.
You can't be everybody
needs to triple down.
If they have one month's worth of cash
and they're burning it,
that is not the right advice.
They need to cut all expenses.
If they are in a little bit
more of a stable situation,
they should triple down
cause fucking prices
of ads on Instagram and
Facebook right now are so low
'cause a lot of people have stopped.
There's so much opportunity.
- Okay, that makes sense.
And it's also your team.
It's loving on your team and your office
and giving them the support as well.
They're all doubling
down too and giving up
everything they have.
We just wanna be there for our clients.
We just wanna walk this with them,
and in the end come out all together,
loving and hugging on each other.
- Sometimes being there is
telling them to spend less
with you.
Sometimes that's the truth.
- Okay, I got it.
- And by the way,
some that can afford to
go harder might double up
their scope once they see
how big the opportunity is.
- Yeah, share of mind no doubt
- Jackie, the right
advice is always selfless.
- Yup
- Always.
Especially when it's hardest.
- Yeah and it doesn't surprise me
that you're saying that as many times
as I've gotten to cross paths
and be in your office and kindness.
When I came in for 4D,
you know what my biggest surprise was?
After all day in your office,
my biggest surprise was,
and I wasn't expecting it,
was the advice and the
love that not only we got
from your whole team,
but Claude, just the love
and the warmth that she gave us that day.
I took that home and went, "That's us,
"we're gonna become an office of empathy,
"kindness, love, compassion,
"and we're gonna double down
"and love every single
day of these clients
"and every single day with this team."
- And it works, right?
Right now is when it shines through.
It's funny because I'm
an aggressive Jersey kid,
so it's a little bit harder to...
To your point, until you kind
of come into the four walls
people will never fully get
it by watching my content.
It's very deep.
The stuff I talk about,
I really mean it.
I'd live it.
- And I love the
transparency of sharing it.
So for all agencies out there,
thank you so much for being
an open book for all of us.
- Thank you.
Bye bye.
For everybody who's watching
what Jackie's referring to is
one of the most unique things
I'm doing is because I'm
putting out all my best advice
for free,
there's a lot of my competitors.
The Sasha group works
with small businesses too.
I'm educating a lot of
my competitors for free
and that is a very unusual model,
definitely in the ad
world and in business.
And so you see it from being community,
but in my direct competitive landscape,
I'm a very interesting enigma.
People are confused by it.
Some people like Jackie really get it.
A lot of people hate
because we've exploded
and we're the fastest growing
and concerning everybody.
But it's really cool.
It's really cool.
All right, let's keep
this going from morning.
Joe what's good?
- What's up Gary?
I'm just pumped.
There's a dude on here.
I love ladies.
We may have to have a
whole full ladies day,
but it's good to see a dude as well.
So Joe, what's up?
- It's good to see you man.
I'm glad I'm finally on here.
So let me just try and dive in.
My question needs a
little bit of prerequisite
first just to explain.
So we own a chain of eight
higher end barber shops
in New Jersey.
We started in 2009.
My brother was 19 years
old when he started it.
I wanna say back in 2016,
I left a six figure job, full time
to work on the business full time.
Since then, we've brought on partners
that have been our barbers,
especially our one
partner Isaac is partners
with us in everything.
And we're beginning to create
what is a brand of eight barber shops,
but a culture and environment.
It's not just the barber shop basically.
We provide our employees
with an environment where they can grow,
where our clients can feel like family.
So it's not just a barbershop.
So basically what I wanna say is this,
without going into too
much is in this industry,
especially with our model,
we pay our barbers really well
and we work on commission base.
Our barbers are full W 2 employees.
So on top of that we have payroll taxes
on top of rent and any
overhead you would think.
So our margins were really low.
So in this industry because
we're trying to build a brand,
continue to grow,
my question is
what can we do besides
having our own product line,
which we already started
and about a year and a half ago
we hired a full time videographer
to create content constantly on Instagram,
YouTube, Facebook, everything.
And besides all that,
how can we utilize the connections
that we're getting through
our clients who love our brand
to generate a bigger profit
in other avenues so that we can continue
to grow more rapidly
than bootstrapping one
after another after another.
Because if we only focus on just--
- Why do we wanna grow more rapidly?
- Well, because our goal
is not to just stay in New Jersey.
Our goal is to grow as a brand.
- How old are you?
- 34
- Okay,
so you have 50 fucking
years to go to Cleveland.
- So what, what do you see besides--
- You do know what happens
in this cliche, right?
Bootstrappers young hustlers do it right.
Brick by brick, brick by
brick, brick by brick,
catch something.
They can feel it.
I feel it.
I pulled you out of the
comments to be on, right?
I feel it.
And then their eyes get big.
They start hearing chirping
from people that are not
in the inner circle.
Right?
Their uncle their most
successful high school buddy.
The guy who's getting his hair cut,
that's a fucking
millionaire on Wall Street.
And people start chirping.
And what happens is they
start to get impatient.
We lost you there for a second.
I wanna make sure you hear this.
(background noise drowns out voice)
There you go.
I can hear you now.
So can you hear me?
- Yeah?
- So they start getting impatient, right?
- So what's also happening is--
(poor connectivity drowns out voice)
- Hey Dustin,
it's two choppy.
You're gonna have to fix him up.
Let's get the next one.
Let's get him back on.
Let's keep this going.
That'll be a part two, cause
it's about to get good.
Roland Edwards.
What's good?
- Whoa,
- Mickey.
- Hey, what's up?
Life is good, where are you from?
- I'm from Ogden, Utah
- It's fantastic.
- Sweet, so hey man,
quick backstory to my question.
About two years ago, I
went to college for a year.
I dropped out I joined
a real estate sales team
to start selling houses.
The leader of the team
approached me one day and said,
"Hey, I want you to run
my social media page."
So I started running the social media page
and little did I know is
that he had another side
of the real estate side.
He had an academy where he
taught agents how to sell houses.
So also having a team on the side
he also taught agents how to sell houses.
And so we have two different programs.
We have the Alliance,
which is $1,000 a year,
and then we have a mastermind,
which is 7,500.
So we have about 60
members in the mastermind
and then about, I don't know,
like a hundred and the Alliance.
So my question is, I've
really gotten good at
the content creation side of things.
I've really studied it.
I'm taking Peng Joon's courses,
so I've been really good at it.
And what we've discussed as a team
is potentially creating content
for our mastermind members,
trying to transition them
from the mastermind into
creating content for them,
and helping them, with their
SOI and things like that
because it's very
important to stay in front
of your audience, especially
for real estate agents.
- I understand.
so I'm trying to communicate
the importance to them.
So how would you transition people from,
one of those types of courses to sound,
like a content creation plan for them
or what would you--
- I mean, are you looking to convert them
to somebody who's paying
you $3,000 a month retainer
or a one off or what's your plan?
- Yeah, we want it to be
like a monthly subscription.
We were thinking around $1,500 a month.
I don't know how you feel
about that as well you can--
- I mean, listen, $15 a month,
15,000 a month, they all play.
It all depends on--
- 1,500, so--
- No, I understand.
- Okay.
- Like I said, $15 a
month or 15,000 a month.
It just comes down to,
supply demand, quality,
the belief of the quality.
If people wanted monthly content
for me it's 30,000 a month
when we did that for Being a Talent.
It comes a lot of different ways.
So I think that the reality is that
I think you need to create
the information around
what you're trying to
do to that mastermind.
What I would probably do,
you said there were 60 people, right?
- Yup.
- I would probably invite
all 60 of them into a zoom
and spend two, three hours
explaining that you guys
are gonna be rolling
this out in three months
and then answering questions
and let them all hear it
and over three hours build up the smoke
to get an opportunity to do something.
- That's a great idea.
- Thank you Mickey.
(laughs)
- Also I followed D-Rock and Babin a lot.
I was just wondering what is your
content creation process
behind the scenes?
'Cause for me, a lot of
our stuff is leveraged out
cause it's just me for content creation.
So I leverage out our graphics,
our subtitles and stuff like that.
What is the process for you guys?
- Meaning do we have it in
house or do we outsource it?
- Yeah.
- It's all in house.
- It's all in house?
- There's a 30 person team on team Gary.
So it's loaded.
- What do you think the
benefits are of that
for little tests like
subtitles and graphics?
- Because I'm teaching those kids,
I'm paying those kids
and then I'm letting them
grow into bigger careers,
whether on my team, whether in VaynerMedia
or whether they use the clout of being
with me to go on and do
other things for themselves.
- Okay so do you recommend--
- It costs me more but, it builds a family
and builds a community.
- Okay, that's very important, okay.
- Yup.
- Cool.
- 'Cause I'm playing longterm,
but it's maybe not the
most financial thing
'cause I can go to Fiverr, I can go to--
- Well for us, we're a
smaller business, so--
- Of course, I think you're
going down the right path,
but the leader needs to think
about really investing in
it longterm and start adding
some overhead to build that culture.
- Okay.
- Awesome, take care Mickey.
- Thank you.
- Talk to you soon.
- Big shout out to Bob Brand McKeel,
Gregory Millard, Greg Ruben.
What's good Bay area getting up early.
Luke, what's good for us?
So Joe, people start hearing other voices,
you started alluding to
it, to where I was going,
the affluent customers start saying,
"Yo, let me put some money in.
"Chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp",
at everything that got you
from one to eight locations.
Now you change up the script
'cause you gotta expand faster,
which I don't understand.
I really don't understand,
I don't want that.
- So, it's not about, expanding.
It's not that we wanna expand faster,
it's more about--
- It's what you said.
- Well, right, but not because of--
I don't feel it's because
of chirping and all that.
It's more because we
work seven days a week.
We have that fire inside
of us that we just want
to keep going, we wanna get our brand out
to more people because we know that
we have something different to offer
than any other barbershop
that we come in contact with.
- I think you might be right.
Eight successful locations.
My biggest problem is if
you wanna start direct
to consumer fucking razors
and fucking shaving cream
or create some sort of
other revenue source,
you're gonna get distracted,
- Right, so the thing is
that the profit margins
are very low in this industry.
- Profit margins are low
in a lot of industries.
Bad profit margins are
in the wine business.
They sell shit.
- So, what was your way of
getting past that,
- Being okay and doing a lot more revenue.
Being 57 and having 183
of these fucking things
across the East coast
and fucking making more, even you--
listen, razor thin margins
at scale become real money.
- Of course, that's the thing.
How do you get to scale when the margins
right now are so small?
- You take a capital
infusion or you stay patient.
- We're trying to--
- Or to your point you innovate
and start another revenue stream
that allows you to not have
to take outside capital.
- We wanna be a brand.
We wanna be a lifestyle brand.
That's what our main goal
and focus is for the future,
is to transition into a lifestyle brand.
We understand that the
draw is the haircuts.
That's how we're gonna draw people in
is with our high quality
haircuts, great customer service,
a great team of barbers
and a great team of
management ownership.
We wanna eventually transition
into being a lifestyle.
Through these years and
through the time of us
building our business,
we've learned a lot.
- Of course.
- And that's the thing is
sometimes we were not sure
whether to help others
grow with our model
or to just stay focused on our model
and continue to grow and
continue the bootstrap slowly.
- Right now is the greatest era
of everybody trying to make money,
giving advice to others based on minimal
or some early success.
What are you gonna start, a mastermind?
What are you gonna start, a course.
- You got the wrong fucking
chirp in your ears, bro.
- That's the chirping
you hear all the time.
Oh, it's about education right now.
It's about this it's
about that and it's like,
yeah, the problem is that that--
It takes a lot to run business.
A lot of people think that barbershops
are absentee businesses
and that's just not true,
it can be if you don't care
- Joe, there's no absentee business.
Show me an absentee business
and I'll show you a business
that's about to go out of business.
- Exactly, that's what I tell people
who wanna open a barber shops.
I say I work seven days a week.
Okay.
And I'm not even a barber.
I don't cut hair.
- You're an operator.
- Exactly.
I work seven days a
week to manage each one
of our barbershops
to deal with any issues that come along
and to coach our barbers through
the good and the bad, okay?
If you think that you're
just gonna open up
a barber shop and let it run itself,
then you're sadly mistaken.
If you think that you're gonna compete
with anyone that even
comes close to what we do.
There's no passive income
the way people dream it up.
You could have a business
that kicks cash every month,
but if you have buildings with rent,
you're gonna have to manage that.
What happens when somebody
burns the fucking building down?
What happens when there's
a crime at your building?
What happens when the
person that's managing
your building dies and you
have to replace him or her?
People are confused out here.
There's work.
- So that's the thing.
When you have employees
and when it's brick and mortar like this,
it's not smooth sailing all the time
and that takes away a lot
of time to be able to do
a lot more things that you wanna do.
There's only so many hours a day,
and trust me, I listen to you all the time
and I'm with you on the fact that...
I'll work 18 hours straight
if I have to, I don't care.
Okay.
And it's just a matter of--
- Love it.
- I love it, I love it.
I left...
Banking, then I worked in retail
and I just loved being an entrepreneur.
I love working I don't even
care if I don't take a paycheck.
I went months a year without taking
even a paycheck.
- I love it.
- And that's the thing is, we love,
and it's not only me, it's myself,
my partner is my brother, Isaac
Shawn, all our partners, Ryan,
we devote so much to the business
and we wanted to just see it grow so much.
I guess what you're saying
is just slow down and,
to reinforce it.
- Joe, you're 34?
- Yes.
- So 34 is when I left
Wine Library day to day
and started VaynerMedia.
I had no money.
I literally started VaynerMedia
in the conference room of Buddy Media
'cause me and AJ had no money.
I literally started at zero, all over.
I didn't make a lot of money
building my dad's business
for him.
And then whatever I saved,
I invested in Facebook and Twitter.
So I felt good about the future.
But it wasn't liquid for a long time.
So I had to build this business
and look where I'm at now at 44.
You're just starting, Joe.
What are you gonna be,
one of those douchebag
entrepreneurs on Instagram?
Stop listening to them.
You think they're having so much fun?
Why?
'Cause I took a photo
of an Instagram model
on a private plane?
Who gives a fuck?
- I agree.
- You can get caught up in a hype.
I can see it, I can smell it
through this fucking screen.
- What we love most more than anything
is seeing our employees grow.
- Good.
That has nothing to do with you expanding
into a monster lifestyle brand.
You're doing it right.
So many people are gonna lose in this era
for doing it right,
getting up a notch,
poking up their head,
'cause they'd been head
down and being like,
"Yo, all these people are having fun.
"All these people are moving fast.
"All these people are getting more.
"I'm fucking working
seven days a week bleeding
"and all these people are
fucking selling bullshit
"and fucking winning.
"What am I doing wrong?
"Dah, dah, dah, dah, dah.
"I gotta learn how to raise capital.
"I gotta expand quicker.
"We gotta fucking create a mastermind
"or a fucking course.
"We're gonna teach other small business."
Like--
- When people come to us and say,
"Hey, we got money.
"We wanna invest in this brand",
and we pretty much turned
them down every single time.
Do you think we're doing the right thing?
- Potentially I mean look,
there is smart money out there.
There's somebody who's passive,
who doesn't give a shit,
who believes so much in you,
who's not gonna bother you
and who doesn't have a board seat
and doesn't have say they're
just getting dividends
kicked out in the future,
if you can get money,
that's passive, that's
chill and that's strategic,
maybe, when Equinox took
money from Steve Ross,
'cause he owned a lot of buildings,
they helped them with a
real estate expansion.
You take a real estate
mogul with a ton of money,
who's she or he's got a ton
of buildings around the world
might be an interesting play
because all of a sudden
you're paying smaller rent.
There's all sorts of
ways to think about it.
Money isn't always bad,
but money for the sake of money is bad.
- Because I also think a lot of people
think that the barber
industry is very cash rich
and it's gonna be a cash cow.
And, first of all, we
accept credit card, so--
- Yeah, Joe I wouldn't worry
about what everybody's perceptions are.
I would stay your course, stay patient.
Look, there's a lot of ways to make money.
Wine Library's margins were shit.
What did I do?
I started buying wines
that were extremely good
that nobody knew and I was
able to make more margin on it.
Reality is if your
brand's poppin so heavy,
every haircut could go up a dollar
they all could, they could.
A dollar is a dollar.
The reality is you could now,
it could be a recession,
and you might have to go down a dollar
but you could.
- Cool,
- People get away from the basics.
You guys built on the basics.
I believe that, there's no way
you would be here without it,
based on the story I heard so,
a dollar extra cut.
starts to change that margin.
- Gary, you gotta come and get a haircut.
I wanna invite you to one of our shops.
- I'm in,
- Awesome.
follow us on Instagram
so we can connect please.
- (laughs) You got it Joe.
- Gary, thank you so much for your time.
- Take care, stay well.
- Thanks.
- Business.
God, this show is fucking awesome.
Just having the time to explain shit.
It's good for me too because it allows me
to show you that deeper level
that I'm actually operating in,
a lot of times you have to be in like
surface level headlines.
It's there, this format's bringing it out.
Hi, Margaret.
- Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- Hi, my kids say hi.
- Hi, kids.
- Okay, so yeah, I sent
two questions in and--
- Whatever you like.
- The first question you did not answer.
But the second question
you guys pick me up on,
and we are starting to listen to your show
every morning now, we're in Toronto.
And the kids are asking Mummy,
why does he swear so much?
(laughs)
And I said to them--(laughs)
And I said, "Oh, Gary's from New York.
"Everyone in New York talks like that.
(laughs)
- I love that.
- So, yeah, I identify a lot with the lady
who called in yesterday, the lawyer,
who had a lot of money and so on and,
I'm 49 this year,
and I'm a divorced mother of two boys.
They are 11 and seven.
We have a very good
relationship with their dad now.
So we're very friendly.
We talk a lot and so
we're all in a good place.
I also run a global
marketing strategy agency,
and we're doing a lot of
high margin stuff right now.
But my question today has
to do with the harder task
of raising children.
- Yes.
- So, my question is,
how do you motivate...
How do you generate that
intrinsic motivation
in very intelligent children,
that we have nine, 10, 11 year olds
with their own e-commerce sites now
they design it on the apple system.
These kids, they
understand about blockchain
about AI, AR,
3D printing, biotech.
They know a lot of knowledge.
They're actually, intelligence
wise, probably smarter
than many adults--
- I fully believe that to be true.
- Yeah.
So the thing is we've got
these really intelligent kids
and I started a separate passion project
just to introduce them to more technology,
jobs of the future and
that's another company
that I have just to
expose them more to that.
But how do you motivate these children
to use their intelligence for
good to make positive change
in the world?
Stuff that you're working on?
How do you get people to share more,
to love more, to bring
humanity to the next level?
- By suffocating bad behavior.
The current generation of
parents are are being too passive
around punishment, and forcing kids
to learn how to make money.
The reality is, we have a
very rich world in the macro
'cause there's a lot
of cash in the system.
Can you hear me?
- Yep.
- Okay.
So, I believe the way you do
it is through suffocating.
One of the ways to get people to focus
on kindness and caring,
is to A, punish when they're
deploying the opposite,
and B, clapping and putting on a pedestal
when they're doing great behavior.
We're all just animals.
And when you're raising an animal,
positive and negative
reinforcement creates frameworks.
We don't have enough
accountability for bad behavior,
and we do not have enough
glory for kind behavior.
It's the same way of how
to build hunger in kids.
Stop buying them things.
Literally my parents, my mom
literally looked at me at 12
and it's like you now buy your own stuff.
And that was tough because
Nintendo was expensive
and Sega was expensive and
we have an entitled generation,
and we don't have repercussions.
We haven't created a framework..
Kids don't get punished anymore.
The fuck?
If your kids a dick you
punish and you punish him
for two weeks and take away his phone,
I have a funny feeling that
he's gonna think about kindness more.
(laughs)
- Okay,
- We don't have a world where there's...
The parenting structure of today,
and this is macro talk,
obviously, there's a lot
of different parents doing
a lot of different things,
but in the macro, the biggest thing
that I'm observing one man's point of view
is we need we need kids
to realize that there are
repercussions for bad behavior.
And the opposite.
When your son opens the
door for an elderly lady,
and you spend an entire week talking
about how remarkable that was,
that's a reinforcement of kind behavior.
I was reinforced as a child,
and others that I see that
are extremely passionate
about kindness
were reinforced in a
culture, in their home,
or their environment that really
put kindness on a pedestal,
but not to the level of delusion,
or ideology or altruism
that wasn't practical.
It wasn't like hippie
shit it was kindness shit.
- Yeah, I think that,
if we are to move the human
race in a positive direction,
there's so many things going on
from global warming to species extinction,
to poverty, to the digital divide.
I mean, if we are to move
the human race forward,
you and I, we have another
maybe 40 years to go,
50 years if we have--
- I'll take 50 more than 40
84 would piss me the
fuck off, I'd be like,
"God, what the fuck I had
some more shit to do."
- Yeah, so it's really
the way that we raise
the next generation and
the sky's the limit for humanity.
- The other way to really think
about raising the next
generation is through action.
One of the most glorious things
that's happened in my career
is over the last three or four years.
I became cool on Instagram,
to a lot of young people,
and then I spent my time
talking about things
like caring and empathy
and kindness and patience.
And all of a sudden those
words are in the lexicon now.
Watching like 22 year old
tough guy entrepreneurs
talk about empathy is maybe
the most gratifying thing in my life.
And so it's not only on the micro,
it's in our behavior as well.
And what we put out, we set
the tone through our actions.
And so I think a lot of grown ups
need to lean into kindness, and
caring and lack of judgment.
I see tons of parents
on Twitter and Facebook
judging the fuck out of people
who they don't even know
and then and then yelling
at their kids to be kinder.
That doesn't fucking work.
- Yeah, yeah, that's good.
- The hypocrisy of parenting.
I see parents all day long talk
about their fear of technology.
But then when they're
having a nice glass of wine
with friends, they give
the iPad to the kid
so they don't bother them.
That's not working.
Your kids being trained to
know you're full of shit.
So we have to be very
thoughtful on how we roll.
- So it's more about not even just having
the hard conversations as you said,
but also doing the hard things first.
- 100% the conversations
kids read through that.
They're too smart.
You know?
It's how you back it up.
It's why punishing matters.
You can't just be like little Ricky,
I don't want you to say that anymore.
You take a phone away from a child,
you take their phone out
of their fucking hand
when they're rude to somebody,
and you take that and put it
into your purse for a week,
watch your kid value kindness more.
- Okay, thank you.
- Thank you have a great day.
- You too.
- That's why I love the streets.
There's repercussions out there.
You do the wrong thing you get
punched in the fucking mouth.
Kids need more to that.
Parents need to be doing.
- Hey, Gary, how's it going?
- It's going super well my man.
What's your name, where you from?
- My name is George, I'm
23 and I'm from Wisconsin.
- I love it George.
- It was funny 'cause
yesterday in the show
you were talking about animation.
And I use animation for education.
My passion is science education.
- I love that.
- But a little bit of backstory.
I'm a visual learner and
I used to create graphics
for me to learn during class.
And in December, I realized
that my passion is sharing this.
So I hit Tik Tok, I hit Instagram.
I hit all the social medias,
and I started just sharing, and I realized
I had such a passion for it.
I wake up every day and
work six, seven hours
creating, creating, creating and sharing.
I have a Shopify account and I
have all this forms of media.
But the thing is,
is that I spend most of my
time creating the graphics.
The majority of the people
that do this kind of thing online,
show about 10% of what they create,
and leave the rest 90% behind a paywall.
And, I mean, it's like I can do that
but it tags on my
heartstrings 'cause I don't.
- Don't do it
- I don't wanna do it.
- Don't do it.
- I wanna share.
- That's why you like me.
I don't do it either.
- I'm out of balance 'cause
I don't know what to do now.
- I got good news, don't do it.
The fuck does anybody else's
life have to do with you?
What are you gonna be sad that
somebody not as good as you
makes a lot more money than you?
Money ain't shit.
- Okay.
Do you have any advice for--
- How to make it sustainable?
Like how to run the business without--
- Yeah.
- How about doing what I do?
I give to the world but
I have corporate clients.
- Okay.
- That's one way.
You could also do...
I love the idea of somebody
this creative doing like a fair,
you could do live events
where you do like one or two events a year
where everybody comes in and
you make money on that event.
Not monetizing your
audience is a very powerful,
opportunity if you're good at
making money outside of them.
And so corporate clients...
You can get into merchandising.
I think merchandising is a very fair play.
My big thing is, if you're kinda--
- I have some merchandise but
the main work is the graphics.
- Understood.
The reality is that if you...
Listen, you're like me,
if you don't feel excited,
if it doesn't feel right to chemicals
on monetizing the audience that way,
then you do it a different way.
And there is no right or wrong.
Listen, monetizing an
audience is more than fine.
It's capitalism.
Nobody forced those people to buy.
But I'm with you.
I think a lot of people think
they're helping audiences,
but what they're putting out
is manipulative content
only to get you to pay.
- Yeah.
- And I struggle with that.
- During this time of social
distancing and quarantine,
I've been holding live events,
where I do study with me videos
and I record the process on YouTube.
Do you have any other advice for things
I can do during this time that
everyone's studying at home?
- Listen, one of the ways that you'll win
is by building a brand.
And then you're able to
monetize different ways.
Maybe you get paid to speak for $25,000.
Maybe you get a TV show,
there's a lot of things
that could happen for you.
So for you, if you're not
gonna monetize the audience,
I think your number one
thing is to give back
to the audience, but
also build your brand.
So for me, what I'm most
worried about right now is
what are you doing on Pinterest?
What are you doing on Tik Tok?
What are you doing on YouTube?
For me, this is about
broadening your brand, you.
You're so young, you can
build a lot of equity
in your brand over time
and then convert it.
- I'm posting every day on Instagram.
I'm posting a lot on Pinterest.
I post five to six times on Tik Tok--
- Five to six times ever,
or five to six times a day?
- A day.
- I love that.
How's that going?
- It's going really good.
I've got about 30,000
followers on Tik Tok,
30,000 followers on Instagram.
I'm trying to learn how to use LinkedIn
for my type of approach.
- I love that.
So you're listening to me clearly.
- Yeah, every day.
- So what are your handles?
Dustin, listen to this.
- My YouTube is Doodles in the Membrane--
- Right there, that was him.
- For Instagram, YouTube
Tik Tok.
It's all the same
- Doodles in the Membrane.
- Yeah.
- And do you sell anything ever?
- Yeah, I sell some merchandise.
I have some sweaters.
I have some stickers.
- I got an idea.
I think you can sell a one day zoom event,
for 50 people at a premium cost
where you go super deep
and you go one on one.
Because what you're doing is like for me,
like for example, this
right here is valuable.
Like if I did this for
you within for an hour.
You pay and not be mad at me
even though I do it for free
because it's so not scalable.
So I don't do it if I can't
make it worth my while,
but nobody would be mad at me
for one hour consultations.
It's no different than a
therapist or a chiropractor
or anything else, I do
think you or a class
like a yoga instructor.
I do think that you have the permission.
I could tell your spirit
So makes me confident in this.
I think you should try to
do a VIP class eight hours
- Okay
- 50 people.
One eight hours, you see where I'm going?
- Yeah.
- You overwhelm them.
Now you're like only
50 people eight hours,
fuck everybody's gonna get
gotten to and I have a feeling
you could do really well and it's the kind
of thing that you could, you know really
do well with and make a couple hundred,
bucks per head or 500 bucks per head
and it could be quite meaningful.
you get 300 bucks per head
on that 50 it starts adding up.
- Yeah.
- 15 G's quick.
How many followers?
How many subscribers
do you have on YouTube?
- I have about 4000 I think
- I love it, all right.
When you got a bunch more yesterday.
That awesome dude with the red beard bar
worth for like 38 to 1000.
So I've everybody thinking
Don James Samy just signed up.
By the way.
Talk about something
that is really valuable
for parents right now for their kids.
They're trying to find activities.
You might have one of the most
important shout, channels.
- Yeah, one of the things
I'm trying to do the most
is I'm not trying to come out my YouTube
and all my social medias as I know
and you don't, I'm
trying to come at it as,
I'm a friend studying with
you at the library and--
- Bro, your demeanor your energy's
fucking off the charts bro.
- Thanks, man, thanks.
- You're gonna win.
Can I give you a good piece of advice?
- Yeah.
- Live stupidly, humbly, like
super humble, like shitty.
Like shitty for like, three, four years.
I have a funny feeling it's
gonna work out for you.
- Well, thanks man.
- If you don't have expenses,
you'll stay patient,
and you'll really crush.
- Okay.
- You see, right doing?
- Yeah,
- If you can keep your overhead down,
live at home live with six buddies,
buying fucking ramen,
like you can.
If you can go there It'll
let you go really patient
In this process,
I'm a very intuitive dude.
Dude I really think you've got it.
- Thank you.
Thank you man it means a lot thanks.
- Take care of yourself.
- You too
- Love you.
I love you back.
Diana what's good TJ what's good?
Mandy read Alibaba it's what's up.
Barry Eisen Byam.
Thank you, Leanne overhead is right.
On that Facebook comment.
What's going on Twitter.
Oh, Jon Law what's good?
- Hello, Gary.
Thanks for having me on the show.
- Thanks for being on the show, bro.
- Okay,
- Where are you from?
- I'm from Bay Area, California.
- How old?
- So to give some context,
I'm 14 and building businesses
and creating content and making money
that's that's like my thing.
That's what I do.
That's what I would love to do.
And I spend all my time doing that.
But I feel right now
I'm working on probably
six different businesses.
I'm doing reselling eCommerce,
affiliate marketing,
some graphic design freelancing.
I'm writing eBooks, hiring
ghost writers to do eBooks
like all this stuff, and I feel like,
my energy is getting split between them
to the point that all of them
are being less successful
than they could otherwise be.
And I enjoy all of them.
So that's not a problem.
But in terms of the potential
of the businesses to long term,
how do you think do you
think I should downsize
or keep going and often
- Go wider.
You're 14, this is the irritation.
Plus a lot of these businesses,
Jon, you're gonna look back
when you were 25 and be like,
I was a scummy kid 'cause
right now the money
is the thing that you're chasing
and I want you to learn process.
I promise on everything I got,
because I'm good with intuition.
You're gonna be embarrassed that you built
some of these businesses,
'cause you know they were just built
for the arbitrage of money.
But I like that you're
learning the process.
So I don't think you have
to go all in on any of them.
I have a funny feeling
you're far more destined in 10 years
to build something quite meaningful,
right now is the year of the k-shit?
- Okay,
- You're learning reps right now, my man
- Okay, and a more specific
question about Instagram
so I'm building a personal brand
on two accounts on Instagram,
two separate accounts
and then I also have two accounts
that are niche pages so I'll post
motivational content and stuff
and that takes a lot of time
and it feels like almost
because it's not a personal brand
it doesn't really reflect on myself
and I'm not sure if it's really--
- Yeah, I would sell them off.
- Sell them, okay
- Sell them to some of
those Pakistania hustlers
that hit me up every day
and all the other people that
buy pages get rid of those.
- Okay.
- So I get it 'cause I'm you at 14
business, business, business.
Is there other things you
give a fuck about like music
or sport or like,
fashion or anything else?
- Yeah, well, I definitely am into sports.
I played sports year round pretty much
I'm competitively doing CrossFit and
One of my personal accounts on Instagram
is a fitness page.
So I'm really into that kind of stuff.
But other than that,
I feel like this is stuff that goes
into the businesses is
a lot more than just...
It's many different things
that I'm interested in that go into that.
- I would learn everything
about art and science.
Right, what I mean by that
is run ads on every platform,
you, make content on every platform,
don't necessarily outsource for scale,
just get dangerous in art and science.
It's a very good skill set for you
in the next hundred years of your life.
- And do you think at this point,
I should be focusing solely on businesses
or like I heard you saying a while ago
that you'd rather have that
two weeks during summer
to go hang out with
friends, should I do that?
- Jon, just so you know,
I didn't even have cell phones.
So when I went in my cocoon
I really went in my cocoon,
but if I had social media
and cell phones and
house party in this shit,
I probably would have...
Bro, I worked every day.
If you hung out one weekend
before this quarantine
thing then you are ready.
So don't get my advice twisted.
You might be getting
that friend time.
I really worked bro. (laughs)
Literally Imagine no Corona normal shit
and the day that you end school this year
you literally go and work 12
hours a day in a liquor store
and come home sleep and then go work again
and then literally do that every day
until you come back to school.
That's what I did
You're doing it for yourself.
I got to get a couple of weekends
here during the school year
for baseball cards, shows
but yeah, I mean, look it
I think you should enjoy
your youth and have some friend time.
But working on your skill matters.
We all look up to Beyonce
and LeBron and guess what?
They didn't have normal childhoods.
If you really wanna go there,
you got to put in the work.
But I do think a little fun is great.
Plus, you were blessed with a...
Dude, your name is fucking amazing.
The whole chats exploding,
they're like his name is Jonny Law.
I mean like, you're fucking set bro.
You can just monetize
your name your whole life.
Bro Listen to me do me one favor,
don't be a scum bucket.
And what I mean by that is
right now you know this.
There's 14 year old who
loves entrepreneurship.
Instagram is littered
with fucking douchebags
that talk about the
lifestyle not the principles
of doing good kindness
businesses promise me
that you don't chase the dollars,
chase the process right now
and learn how to be honorable,
because I promise you Jonny
if you remember anything
I fucking ever tell you,
how you make your money
is way more important
than how much you make.
- Got it.
Thank you
- Promise me.
It can catch you, young Dude,
the lifestyle, the nightlife,
the guys, the girls I get it.
But I'm telling you,
I'm telling you promise me,
because you know how I'm
different than some of the other
voices that are out there.
Please stay the course on this.
- All right, I will, I will.
- Do you understand what I'm saying?
- Yes, yes.
- Good.
- Okay.
- Thank you, so much.
- You go it brother, talk to you soon.
All right.
God, I'm really in it today.
Bad news.
I gotta drop in 22 minutes.
Got some business thing that popped up.
So 10:30 today,
you know?
Hi.
- Can you hear me?
- I can hear you.
- So I know you're trying
to do this yesterday,
but it really like wasn't going through.
- Today it is.
What's your name, where you from?
- Oh, my name is Ashley.
I'm actually from New York,
I know my hoodie says Atlanta,
but I actually live in New
York City right now so--
- Okay Ash.
- That is that.
Thank you so much for everything.
You have been an inspiration for a while
and I have been following you.
So I do really appreciate that.
- Thank you.
I guess my question to
you is you always talk
about your parents and how they've had
such a big impact on your life
and they've kind of been that framework
and helping you just really
become who you are today.
I guess my question was
what advice you have for people
who really don't have that framework,
but are super ambitious
and they really want that direction.
How do you figure--
- Listen, I'll be very honest with you.
My dad didn't have it.
And my dad put that chip on his shoulder
and went and used the
energy in a different way.
So, listen, there's unlimited people
that are kind and crushing the world
who didn't have parents they looked up to.
And so, I feel comfortable talking
about all the blessings I was given,
but I always remind people,
if one person made it that looks like you,
then you can, too so A,
first it's about not dwelling.
The biggest thing that people...
I love how your head
went off on that, right?
Like, the number one thing that I see
is people dwelling about shit
they couldn't control, right?
You don't get to pick your parents.
You don't get to pick where you're born.
So, to me the second
you move into optimism and gratitude...
Oh, gratitude and optimism go.
Team, I like something
I think I got a hoodie.
Go, gratitude and optimism the second...
It's crazy my brain just clicked
Fuck, that's amazing.
Literally when your mindset
is gratitude and optimism,
then you can go.
- Definitely
- When you're dwelling and looking back,
you're fucking stuck forever.
So, sometimes you get the
fortunate thing to look up
to a parent.
Sometimes you get the
fortunate thing of looking up
to a grandparent, an uncle,
a best friend, a best friend's parent,
somebody you saw on TV,
somebody watch on the internet,
it's about leading into positivity.
- Definitely.
- That's the answer, actually.
Honestly, it's about what
you put into your ears
and through your eyes is your life.
- No, I've definitely learned that
and I feel like through my life,
I've gained a lot of experience.
I've ended up, like you
just started saying,
I've worked since I was like 11, 12.
My mom passed away around that time,
and I've been working since then,
and I feel like I've had older
brothers, older everybody
and people who are always like,
"Hey, you're super wise,
"you're the one to look to."
But it's like, I'm the
youngest of everybody.
Who do I look to?
And so--
- Yourself, yourself.
Look within yourself.
I give a lot of gaps to my parents,
but let me promise you,
it's all been in myself in my own head.
- Yeah.
I think it's just like balancing
that sense of confidence,
but also that humility, like
you said, the, I don't know--
- No, no, no.
Stick with me, stick me.
I like where this is going.
It's gonna help a lot of people.
I'm as confident as it gets,
but you can be humble.
If you're worried about that part,
the other part is, don't put rules on you.
When you're the youngest
and you were born as an old wise soul.
And it's on your shoulders,
like you're gonna get us out,
you're the one that's gonna do it,
don't put a time limit on it.
Don't put that pressure.
You gotta live for you.
And the more you live for you,
if it goes then other people will benefit.
You can't worry about outside forces.
- Definitely, okay.
- Listen to me Ash,
I'm not letting you go.
'cause I feel like there's
more work to be done here.
Listen to me.
Keep playing with me here.
What are you really thinking?
What's fucking with you?
Help me.
Help me help you.
On real shit.
- I think just getting out of my own way.
I have a lot of really cool ideas,
I have a lot of really...
I think I do have a lot of people
who are behind me immediately.
I don't really have a super big following
on Instagram but just person
to person I worked in retail,
I worked in food, I worked in just
a lot of these personable industries
and I find that a lot of people
just gravitate towards my energy,
but it's like, I just don't
know what to give back out.
- What do you do?
Like, what do you make?
Can you make content?
- I wanted to start doing
a YouTube channel because--
- Are you able to do
design and video work?
- I wanted to get in
there for the most part,
I was drawing and painting and whatnot.
But I wanted to get more
in the digital realm
and just use my face as a
platform for myself. (laughs)
So, I don't know
- Do you have a job.
- I was working at a restaurant,
but since the whole COVID thing,
and then I was a manager before that,
but I just completely
tapped out of that role,
'cause again, I realized
you can get a certain amount of money,
but again I just--
- Ash
- Do you think you can write?
- I said I was gonna
start journaling today.
I have a journal, yeah, yeah.
- Are you good at ideas?
- I think so.
- How much of my content
have you consumed?
- I've consumed it over the years,
by now you definitely
have like a cult following
that's not--
- Yeah, yeah, forget about that,
- But you have a general sense
of what I'm talking about.
- Definitely.
- Listen to me.
I really, really, really, really
think you should email me.
I think you should work
on my team at VaynerMedia.
- Stop.
That would be dope.
- I'm being dead fucking serious.
- I am super fucking serious to Gary.
- Okay, so do me a favor.
I want you to email me at
Gary@VaynerMedia right now,
and I want you to put in the title,
"Hey, it's me, Ashley,
the girl from New York,
"wearing the Atlanta hoodie."
- Gotcha.
I gotcha, I gotcha.
Thank you so much.
My hands are like shaking--
- Listen to me, on my team
you have to make ideas.
You have to write and you have
to make videos or pictures.
The drawing interests me.
You don't follow me
enough to maybe know this,
but I like putting cartoons in my content.
I think we could do drawings,
I'm gonna have Andy or D-Rock or Sid
or May or Katie reach out to
you today after you email me,
and we're gonna start
giving you some stuff
to see what you can make
and then the next couple weeks
or maybe when this is over,
we're gonna fucking hire
you to be on my team.
- That's dope, I'm ready
whenever you need, I gotcha.
- All right, I'll see you soon.
- Thank you so much.
- Dustin.
- Yes, sir.
- You just met your new teammate.
- (laughs) Looking forward
to working together.
- You saw that coming
from a mile away, right?
- I think the people in the comments
saw it way before I did,
they were like, "Here it
comes, here it comes."
And I was like, "Here's what comes."
And then it clicked for me.
- We're giving out jobs here
On Tea With GaryVee giving out jobs?
Giving out jobs during the Corona.
There's something I feel about her.
I feel like she needs us
and then we'll figure out
how to get her to help us.
- Very cool.
- Very cool indeed.
- Oh, I'm on.
- Craig, you good, you're here.
- What's up man?
- Life is good bro.
- My wife.
What's up brother?
I'm in Houston man.
- Beautiful.
You love Kobi
- I love Kobi man, R.I.P
Kobi, that's my guy.
My inspiration man.
- It's just so devastating.
I can't believe he's not with us.
- Huge man, huge.
But he is, he is, man.
I think he's in all of us.
Whenever
- I think that's right.
He left real impact.
- That's real true.
- For sure, for sure.
- Craig, what can help you with?
- All right Gary man, here's the thing,
I retired from playing ball
like in 2008, 2018.
And, one thing about it, man,
I feel like a lot of guys
are like, "No, no judging,"
but I don't wanna get on here
to try to prove that I'm
cool or prove that people
should rock with me.
I feel like that's me in a nature.
- You have a great personality.
- Thanks man, thanks.
but what I've been struggling with,
since I retired, man,
I've always been entrepreneurial by heart.
even my playing career, man,
if you found out how I started playing,
you wouldn't believe it
bro this is crazy story.
- You hustled it?
- Yeah, man, literally I was working at..
I was going at 24 Hour Fitness
training with some friends,
and I wanted to play pro.
I had a guy that was playing
in Turkey making crazy money,
but I love the game I always want to prove
to my coaches, everyone,
'cause I was like a mid level player, man.
I know I didn't play at a big school.
I just had the chip on my shoulder,
I played at DIII in Texas,
but I'm like, "I'm going pro,"
I wanted to make this just
'cause I love to play.
And man, I was working and a guy came in
played baseball, but he
came in with his friend,
a nice chick and by the end
of the conversation man,
He was asking me like,
"Dude, you're big,
"what are you doing
working in a restaurant?
"What are you doing
working at a steak house?"
And I was "Got good personality
man and I like one."
So I ended up, waiting on him and
this was actually my last straw basically.
I had spilled some shit.
It wasn't going well at this place.
(laughs)
(poor reception drowns out voice)
- Bro, there's nothing that
fires me up more than hearing,
"I spilled some shit."
- Yeah
I love it, keep going.
- And this is high
quality steak house, man.
So I'm like "Damn."
- You were about to go,
that manager was kicking you out.
- For sure, for sure.
- I got it.
Man, but at the end of the night
the last table guy came in,
just real cool guy, man.
I told him I was actually
working to save up money
to go to a camp in Serbia
just to give myself a shot.
I heard about this camp.
I was like, "Let me get out the bucket--"
- Because at that point you
knew that Europe overseas
had some money and that
was more likely to be
where you were gonna play.
- It just was like I did the D league
tried to D league route.
I heard it was just immediate.
Literally Nick Nurse,
was the coach at the
RGV Vipers at the time
and he sat me down and
he was real with me.
He was like, "Listen, your
talent level can be X amount,
"but you have high level guys,"
I think it was Chris Lofton on the board.
You have all these names
that I have to sell
to these guys above me
why we should take them.
So no matter what your talent level is,
these guys are gonna stand out more.
- I got it.
- I said, okay I get it,
I literally took a bus
from Houston down to the Valley.
My agent called me, he's like,
"They want you to work out tomorrow."
I did that like in a day
just 'cause I love the game.
But yeah, man,
I met him and by the
end of the dinner man,
that guy was just like,
he wrote me a check
for 900 bucks to buy my plane ticket.
I had already made enough
to pay for the camp.
So went over there man, kill good.
And the rest was history, man.
- Where'd you play?
- I played in Germany, Saudi Arabia,
Cyprus, Mexico, basically got
a chance to play all over man.
- I love that.
Good for you bro.
Got to see the world,
Got to play your game.
Good for you, man.
- I'll tell you,
my first gig I made
the entire season,
probably about 600 euros.
- I get it, it's a grind, bro.
It's a grind.
When you love something.
Yeah, I get it my man.
Okay, what can I answer before I bounce?
- So, basically what I'm
trying to figure out,
man, I'm getting stuck between,
I tried so many different things.
I went to the car business,
I did really well in that
moved up into finance
because I know I need money
and I'm always motivated by that.
So I'm getting stuck between,
I wanna continue that aspect.
I started a trucking company,
and I've been doing that
and at the same time
I teach, I train and I teach kids.
So, I love to do both, man.
But what I'm stuck between
is trying to figure that out.
I'm trying to figure out how can I,
build my business,
my trucking company and at the same time
give the game back because
that gives me the joy.
- So you're caught between
happiness and cash.
That's what's happening.
You've got the business
You get it.
You've got your life,
you've got a lifestyle you want to live,
but the game is so deep
in your fucking soul
and you wanna fucking
give back and do that,
but the money is not as much there.
A couple of things to think about.
Are you the only business owner,
of the trucking or is it a partnership.
- No, it's just me right now.
- One of the things
I see in these scenarios is
you might wanna bring in somebody
and give them 30% of the business
they have to earn into it.
You can five points
every year for six years,
but she or he could run that business.
All of a sudden you've got somebody
who gives a fuck about the business
'cause they got nothing.
Now they're coming up and
they're gonna work hard
to get to that 30% ownership.
Somebody you know,
somebody you get to know
maybe an employee or manager,
what have you,
which then allows you
to actually go all in.
I'll be honest with you,
with this level of charisma
and swag and looks, I
think you could be...
I think you could really
build a basketball academy
virtual business where you're
training individual kids,
but then the shit we all grew up with,
the VHS tapes tapes on fucking cable,
you can now be doing that as
a class online and people are
paying 19 bucks a month to get the content
and to get three hours with you in a zoom.
I'm really pushing people
heavy on these zoom
and Google Hangouts.
You could have a hundred
people a night in a zoom,
three hours worth of questions,
do that two nights a week.
I mean there's a lot of opportunity
for somebody with this
kind of personality trait
and this kind of passion.
I'm convinced, by the way, Craig,
this is on some real shit,
I'm convinced you would make more money
in the basketball thing than
in the trucking company,
It's just that you have
to deploy massive humility
for seven years.
- What do you mean by that?
Just get into it?
- You're not gonna make as much
money the first seven years,
but by year eight you'll make more.
So your lifestyle adjustments
would have to map that
because you don't give a
fuck about the trucking shit.
You're fucking making the ROI, the money,
and I respect that, but
I really, really think
you've got to look at
monetizing the basketball thing
one on one training and virtual content.
I think you could build a real business.
- So here's my only hiccup on that
and I agree with that.
- Go ahead, go ahead.
- My daughter,
I have a daughter,
and I have a family.
I took a backseat
literally I took the Kobi approach,
I read an interview with Kobi was like,
he felt like he could make...
Bounce over other guys when
he first came in league,
'cause he didn't have a family.
He didn't have to obligate
that time to do it.
So for me it's like I literally, man,
that's what I adapted when it came to...
I was in a gym eight hours a day.
I knew I was not naturally good enough.
So I wanna work harder and get better and
become a perfectionist
actually learned the craft,
the movements, everything so,
that takes time.
That's how I am when
it comes to everything,
when it comes to business,
now adapt with it.
I feel like if I wanna blow it up,
I know what I have to do.
I have to really lock in and knock it out.
So sometimes it feels like,
how do you spread yourself...
If you are a perfectionist on both sides,
how do you make that happen?
- By starting the process
to not judge yourself.
Perfectionism is bullshit.
It's fear it's a disguise.
People use it as a disguise, bro.
Perfectionism is an excuse.
I'm telling you it is.
Perfectionism is fucking
insecurity with lipstick on.
Don't judge yourself.
If you're in the gym all day
and you got hot and you
figured something out
and you came late and
you missed that dinner,
that's one dinner,
make it up next week,
make it up next week.
Take her for a walk, spend
the whole day with her.
Everyone's judging themselves.
- Yeah.
- Don't judge yourself in a day.
Judge yourself in a life.
- I got you bro.
And you're my big brother.
You might not know it, man,
but you're my big brother.
I listen to Jeezy every day
and I hear your voice start it
and it just pushes me man.
- I appreciate it.
I appreciate that.
- Thank you man.
- I'll talk to you soon.
- Be safe.
Alright, Dustin, let's wrap this up.
Last five minutes.
Great show.
I'm sorry it's 30 minutes shorter today.
but I really appreciate it.
I thought we did some
real stuff today, man,
there was some real stuff.
We gave away a job, we
gave out some advice.
There was a 14 year old
and the lady started off right.
Dustin, we're gonna have
to go with four ladies
in a row next time too,
they started off right,
and then we came in with a 14 year olds
and we gave out a job.
We did a lot of stuff today Dus.
I felt really good about this show.
I really did.
You know what we didn't do,
we didn't sign up anybody
for WineText.
Throw that shit up there, Dustin.
Let's get that up.
There it is.
Today, in an hour and a
half, if you don't sign up
before the text goes out, you
just missed the whole day.
So right now as you wrap up,
if you buy wine on the internet,
if you buy wine in the internet,
flat out, sign up for WineText.
Today's Rose is super crazy good,
super crazy good.
Crazy discount on it too.
So definitely check that out.
I just appreciate all of you.
Let me give a couple of little shout outs
before we're out Hacky
Wraps, Juniour Softy.
What's good.
Appreciate you signing
up yesterday Juniour,
Richard, what's good
team GaryVee with that,
Paul, Russ,
really good show.
I hope that you took
some value out of this.
I've been really enjoying the show.
I'm really enjoying bringing value.
I really adore all of you,
please take a screenshot.
Oh, if you sign up for WineText right now,
when you get the final thank
you screen, take a picture,
tweet me at it I wanna
follow you right now.
Let's wrap with that, if you do that.
And, that was just a good show.
Please hit me up on
Twitter with your favorite,
moments from the show
and also throw up the two-one-two, Dustin,
if you wanna get on the show,
text me 212-931-5731
212-931-5731
Text your question and put
hashtag Tea With GaryVee,
and the team will reach out to
you and put you on the show.
Hit me up with Twitter
with your highlights,
Facebook, YouTube, LinkedIn.
Thank you so much for watching Instagram.
What's good?
I really appreciate it.
Let me read a couple of
comments here before we're out.
Kwame, thank you so much.
Matthias, thank you.
Jon Law Fitness.
Jon law.
Good job today.
Jonny law.
Ken McGuire, what's good?
Julio Spinosa in the building.
All right, everybody have a wonderful,
wonderful, wonderful day.
I'm gonna spend two minutes
following you guys on Twitter.
See ya.
Thanks Dustin.
- Okay, so team Gary has made
a lot of content over the years,
but what's your favorite piece
of content that was made?
- That's a Great question.
My favorite content
by far is I'm considering
doing a VaynerMedia operation
stay-at-home-day once a week forever,
'cause I'm pretty sold
that I've gotten more
done per day than sometimes in a month.